this morning the coronavirus crisis is
escalating across america and in several
other countries across the globe public
health officials in the u.s reported
more than 62 000 new cases of
the illness yesterday and the nation's
one day death toll was 1124. now that
tops
a thousand for the first time in nearly
a month wisconsin also reported its
highest number of cova deaths in a
single day
in a cbs news exclusive and an important
one adriana diaz went
inside one of five coveted units in
wisconsin's largest hospital
to see what patients and medical teams
are up against
hi sue hi how are you 73 year old sue
pappas says she did everything she could
to protect herself from the coronavirus
that's why she's angry
she still ended up in the icu at aurora
st
luke's medical center in milwaukee what
do you say to people who don't believe
this is real i i don't know what to say
to them
i'm sitting here i'm sicker than god in
dog
and it's real how do you think she's
gonna do
i feel good about her i really do it's
hard to say though because we've seen
patients
that hang out and on high oxygen for
weeks and then they require
intubation and it happens fast
ashley bonus is one of pappas nurses
she's also
17 weeks pregnant i struggle with going
to
the gas station and someone's not
wearing a mask because i am
i am a diabetic i am a pregnant woman
like
i'm risking more going to the store than
i am coming to work because i know that
we're all 100 percent protected here
in the past month the number of coped
patients here has more than tripled
this patient has been intubated and
sedated and has been here for two weeks
one two three the reason why they're
flipping him is because
proning as it's called or flipping
patients has been shown to help patients
breathe better
it's one of the proven ways to help them
survive dr charles ogello who secured
the patient's head
worries about the staff at some point
fatigue begins to set in
how do we keep our staff refreshed and
able to continue to do this
since it's lasting longer and longer
it's been a marathon
it has been a marathon and we don't know
when it's going to end
despite the uncertainty the nurses and
doctors here say they're fueled by the
people they're able to save
when we started this i asked my husband
who fought in the war in afghanistan as
a marine
how do you prepare for this this battle
he told me
to figure out what you're fighting for
and keep that at the forefront
so this community these these patients
these families that are being affected
by this
that's what i'm fighting for for cbs
this morning
adriana diaz milwaukee
wow you cannot help but think about
ashley bonus there tony
i mean oh absolutely and you know i said
at the top that that was a cbs news
exclusive and an important one the
reason i think it's so
important is because we have covered
grieving families we've covered people
who have recovered from the virus
but what we're seeing and it is rare is
actual patients
struggling and i think that brings it
home for americans who may be still
thinking you know i don't see it in my
community
what's really going on here well we just
showed it to you and frontline workers
struggling a reminder ashley bonus is is
diabetic
a nurse working in the hospital diabetic
and 17 weeks pregnant
that's why guys it's so hard to hear
people say we've rounded a corner we
have it under control
try to try telling that to the people on
the front lines that are dealing with
this on a on a daily basis it's
very much alive and thriving in this
country please don't forget that an
important story by adriana